what is your hope here for um
for this part of the world do do you see
a possible future with a two-state
solution whether you're Palestine and
Israel do you see a one-state solution
where there is uh A diversity of
different peoples like in the United
States and they have equal rights
in the courts than everywhere else
you know I don't think there's a
geography solution is is possible
um as we said earlier swiss cheese
there's literally uh supplements all
over the West Bank
um
and I don't think it's fair
um at least it's also not fair to all of
the people whose homes
um
are still in heifer
in Nazareth in yafa and so far and I
don't think it's fair that like I'm
gonna have to
travel to another country to visit my
cousin who's married in Nazareth for
example
um
and beyond that it's just not possible
I do believe that whatever you want to
call it one state to stay 48 states 29
States whatever you want to call it
refugees need to return land needs to be
given back
wealth needs to be redistributed
and a recognition of the nakba needs to
happen that is the only way we could
move forward
um and you know regarding whether this
is like a possible situation
for two people
to live side by side
let's ask two questions
let's say you you lived in a house
with a person your roommate you just had
a roommate who constantly beat the
out of you
I wonder if you'd want to continue to
live with them that's one
and let's try another scenario let's say
you live in a house with a roommate who
you just
absolutely hate
absolutely oppose their existence as a
people
um you don't even give him you know a
key to your to your apartment
let's say now you're like equal Partners
in the apartment would you want to give
would you want to live with him I don't
know we'll see we'll see time will tell
but you know I don't think I don't think
they want to live with us Israelis are
quite good you know especially Israeli
diplomats they're quite good at
um using
uh flowery language about peace and
coexistence and so on and so forth and
they're good about they're good with
making us seem insane or radical or like
full of hate and so on and so forth but
the but the but the policies speak from
the from for themselves the the actions
on the ground speak for themselves and I
I truly I mean every time there's an
optic many of them leave and
I wonder I would like to see I wonder
what would happen in one state solution